[Music]
performing reliably
on unseen or shifting data distributions
is a difficult challenge for modern
vision systems
even slight corruptions or
transformations of images
are enough to slash the accuracy of
state-of-the-art classifiers
when an adversary is allowed to
manipulate or modify an image directly
then models can be manipulated into
predicting
anything even when there's no
perceptible change
this is known as an adversarial example
the ideal definition of an adversarial
example
is when two humans consistently say that
two pictures are the same
but a machine disagrees but we can't
operationalize that
therefore many researchers look at the
l2 or the l infinity distance
between two images as a proxy for human
evaluation
hardy salman is a phd student at the
madre lab at mit
he cut his teeth at the robotics
institute
at carnegie mellon at uber and at
microsoft research
during his undergrad at the american
university of beirut
hardy became fascinated with robotics
and autonomous systems
what excited him the most was that
building such an intelligent system
could assist humans in making their
lives much
easier hardy was fascinated by the
potential for artificial intelligence
to make robots behave increasingly
like living things he realized that
robots without a high
level of intelligence would always be
lacking
something critical after several years
of research in robotics
he quickly realized that his passion
went beyond
applying artificial intelligence to
robots his experience with robots and
autonomous vehicles
made him aware of some fundamental
issues in artificial intelligence
which hinders it from being used
reliably in safety critical applications
chief of which is the brittleness of ai
models in general
their sensitivity to distribution shifts
random corruptions and adversarial
examples
not even to mention the safety and
security concerns
that lie therein hardy became enmeshed
in the pursuit of these problems above
all else and he did some pivotal work
with some
world-class researchers at microsoft
research
so what does it mean for a model to be
vulnerable
to adversarial perturbation let's just
say that an adversarial perturbation is
when
an imperceptible change can be made to
an image
transmogrifying its predicted class
the robustness of a model has
traditionally meant its susceptibility
to noise
but it's also been used synonymously for
generalization
itself when hardy was at microsoft he
came across a couple of papers from his
current lab at mit the first one
was adversarial examples are not bugs
they are
features it presented an entirely new
perspective for understanding our data
referred to as the robust features
model a robust feature is one which is
anthropocentric or recognizable
by humans in this model the brittleness
of neural networks
is justified by the sensitivity of
models to highly generalizing
and so-called non-robust features
of the data right which are
imperceptible
and unrecognizable for humans
the supervised paradigm of machine
learning maximizes accuracy alone
it's little wonder that classifiers use
all of the information available
even if it's incomprehensible to humans
the mit researchers showed that it's
possible to disentangle
the robust features from the non-robust
features
by doing adversarial training or so
called
robustification robustification is when
adversarial examples are found using
projected gradient descent
it only finds the smaller magnitude
non-robust features
because the algorithm is constrained to
a small radius
around the original sample so by
definition any of the features it finds
are the low magnitude or non-robust
features
just because you do adversarial training
it doesn't necessarily mean you're going
to block
all of the adversarial examples so
robustness will always be a matter of
degree
normally classifiers learn both sets of
features
in tandem but when you isolate them into
separate data sets and you train a model
on both of them
you'll get a good classifier in both
cases
this demonstrates that both of these
projections of your data
are just two different types of features
it's only when you train on the robust
features
that you get a robust classifier which
is to say
a classifier which is primarily learning
human recognizable features previously
adversarial examples were seen as
aberrations
arising from the high dimensional nature
of the input space
or statistical fluctuations of the
training data
this new frame of reference suddenly
explained why adversarial examples
transferred between models they were in
the data this conception doesn't explain
all adversarial examples it's still
possible to find ones which
don't generalize outside of the training
data but why not leave the robust
features in there you might ask
they still carry predictive information
even if
imperceptible to humans herein lays the
tragedy
if you remove all of the non-robust
features your classifier accuracy will
drop
but at least there'll be an alignment
between what humans recognize
and what your model is learning the
second paper which inspired hardy from
the mit lab
was adversarial robustness as a prior
for learned representations which
demonstrated that adversarial robustness
leads to more human perception aligned
feature representations
robust optimization can actually be
viewed as inducing a human prior
over the features that the models are
able to learn so in that paper there was
a really interesting experiment where
they
trained a robust network on robust
features and a non-robust
network on non-robust features they then
put in either an input image or
just a random seed image
and then they run projected gradient
descent to maximally
activate a given output class
back into the original image and you can
see that on the robust network
the kind of shapes that are emerging are
quite high level they're quite human
recognizable we have something that
looks quite frog like in the top left
here and
quite crab-like whereas on the
non-robust features we're just seeing
noise these are
imperceptible to humans and when the dog
was used as a seed
image you're still seeing the dog kind
of bleeding through
into the optimized image so as you can
see these just seem like two completely
orthogonal sets of features
but annoyingly for us the non-robust
features below
are highly generalizing and are being
learned by neural networks
in their default configuration it's a
fairly empirical method that they use
trying to ascertain whether an image is
human recognizable or anthropocentric to
a certain extent but yeah it's it's
quite clear though that the more robust
the network
the more it produces human interpretable
visualizations
larger shapes and configurations of
objects rather than these
fine-grained or ostensibly noisy
patterns
do you remember whelan brendel who he
had on the show recently
he was involved in that texture bias
paper showing that cnns are strongly
biased towards recognizing textures
rather than shapes he claimed that if
you have a robust network
then they're not sensitive to the
textures anymore and they're more likely
to be aligned
to the features that humans pay
attention to
so all of this work inspired hardy to
start thinking about how the fruits of
the adversarial robustness community
could be leveraged beyond security
hardy published work showing that using
adversarial robustness as a prior for
training
during imagenet models actually led to
better transfer learning
to a wide range of downstream tasks a
few months later
hardy had a huge realization the
phenomenon of adversarial examples can
actually be turned
upside down to lead to more robust
models
instead of breaking them hardy actually
utilized the brittleness of neural
networks
to design unadversarial examples
or robust objects which are objects
designed specifically
to be robustly recognized by neural
networks
this work led to hardy publishing the
paper unadversarial examples
designing objects for robust vision
which basically answers the question
why are we trying so hard to make neural
networks
robustly recognize objects
why don't we turn this thing upside down
and instead
optimize our objects to be robustly
recognized
by neural networks how can we build
objects that are easily detectable by
machine learning models
instead of optimizing images to mislead
the models
as is the case in traditional
adversarial examples
we can instead alter the inputs to
reinforce the correct behavior
yielding on adversarial examples
consider how adversarial examples work
we maximize the loss of a machine
learning model
given the correct label with respect to
the input image
by solving a simple projected gradient
descent formulation
finding permissible but small
perturbations
on the input image to make this work for
unadversarial examples
all we need to do is change the max to a
min
we can do this on entire images but to
make it even more realistic we can work
with patches
or even textures on the objects inside
the image
this works brilliantly in settings where
the user not only has control on the
models that they're deploying
but also on the objects of interest that
they're trying to recognize
track or detect we already do this in
the real world right just think about
helicopter landing pads or runways
or stop signs these are things that have
been designed
to perceptually activate our own human
perception
as much as possible and it turns out
that we can do the same thing
for machines anyway i really hope you
enjoyed the episode today we've had so
much fun making it
remember to like comment and subscribe
we love reading your comments and we'll
see you back
for some quantum natural language
processing
next week check out me hat
what the hell is that oh nice
look it has my pronouns
excellence conflating pronouns with
editors
there is a secret it has the tweets that
got me into trouble
welcome back to the machine learning
street talk youtube channel
and podcast with by two compadres sayak
the neural network pruner pool
and dr yannick lightspeed
culture now in today's show we are
joined by hardy
salman hardy pursued a double major in
mathematics
and mechanical engineering at the
american university of beirut
he obtained a masters in robotics from
carnegie mellon
under the tutelage of the legendary
professor howie chossit
where he applied machine learning in
tumor localization
and surgical robots he also applied deep
reinforcement learning for robot
navigation
hardy interned at uber where he worked
at the intersection
of machine learning and uncertainty
quantification for autonomous driving
and he also got accepted into
microsoft's ai residency program
in 2018 which is really prestigious
actually i think only about
10 people got accepted from literally
thousands of applicants
so he spent two and a half years at msr
as a research engineer
working on adversarial robustness for
neural networks
and whilst he was there he published a
convex relaxation barrier
to tight robustness verification of
neural networks
and this work was a layer-wise convex
relaxation framework that unified
all the previous lp relaxed neural
network verifiers i think lp means
linear programming by the way
um in primal and dual spaces he also
published provably robust deep learning
via adversarially trained
smooth classifiers which improved the
performance of randomized smoothing
and is now one of the few scalable and
certified defenses against lp bounded or
finite dimensional adversarial examples
this work achieved sotter accuracy on
imagenet and on cifar10
he also released the paper denoised
smoothing a provable defense for
pre-trained classifiers
where he developed a method for provably
defending
any pre-trained image classifier against
finite dimensional adversarial attacks
at the end of last year hardy published
unadversarial examples
designing objects for robust vision
hardy realized that the phenomenon
of adversarial examples can actually be
reversed
to lead to more robust models instead of
breaking
these models how to utilize the
brittleness of neural networks to design
robust objects or unadversary examples
he also published do adversarially
robust imagenet models transfer better
at the end of last year robust base
models for transfer learning might
actually have
you know slightly lower accuracy but
they transfer better for downstream
tasks
robustness leads to better feature
representations
recently heidi joined the mit madre lab
as a phd student where he's developing
techniques for efficient
reliable and safe deployment of machine
learning models
in the real world and today hardy is
going to tell us all about his work on
adversarial robustness
beyond security anyway uh hardy it's an
absolute honor to have you on the show
tell us about your eureka moment with un
adversarial examples
thanks guys for having me in the show
this is a great show and i'm happy to be
here
um and thanks for the great introduction
so yeah like addressing examples are
amazing as a phenomenon it always
actually like
surprised me like and got me really
excited i remember
attending a talk like uh by uh by one of
like facebook air researchers uh
uh facebook i researched uh researchers
which gave it which is what he gave it
at cmu and he kind of talked about i
forgot his name to be honest
but uh he gave it he gave a talk at cmu
and he introduced hundreds of examples
and i was really really impressed and i
was like oh my god this is great like
this is nice like
like how how can you know those you know
very easy easily crafted examples you
know break break such like really really
well working models like you know they
work in like in very high dimensional
space you start you just perturb your
image slightly and you suddenly break
the model
it's really impressive and you know this
got me to like you know to realize like
you know like
our current models they work really well
you know
in the average case but on the worst
case scenario they just like you know
suck
it's very very easy i can't imagine how
easy it is to like break
these models so it's clear that you know
like our current uh
you know machine learning models are way
um
you know like way far from being robust
and reliable in a way that we want them
to be
when we deploy them and especially in
specifically critical applications
so for me the recent example is really
like kind of like from a security
perspective it's really like
an important problem although people
like some people think that you know
uh there are more more problems that you
know like there are worse problems than
ever
examples currently that we should focus
on which i agree with but that's still
adversity examples is definitely like at
least in the future it's gonna be like
something we have to deal with and uh
currently also we have to deal with as
well
um so from a security perspective you
know i've uh i've done i've done some
work as you mentioned the
adversary examples and it's really
exciting like
the nice thing about it is that it's
really challenging
like like there's literally like it's
easy to attack you know there are many
many attacks
all of them work amazing but it's very
very difficult
to defend against these attacks like
it's it's it's insanely difficult
even though it's on small small data
sets like c410 we cannot achieve like
you know above like 60
67 accuracy on like some even like you
know small lp preservations
it's just like insane how how how
difficult it is to defend
um and how about certifiably defend as
well like with guarantees that even
becomes harder and harder
and whenever you try to defend the
problem is like whenever you're trying
to defend against these things you
lose accuracy as well you do you lose
standard performance
so every single defense that we have
right now it doesn't even like you know
achieve like you know the robustness
level that we want
but in addition to that you know it
suffers from you know
bad accuracy and also sometimes like if
you're using randomized smoothing or
something it's practically
difficult as well because you need like
a hundred thousand samples
at inference time to like get some
certificate
so like some some search feed of
robustness which is clearly like nothing
like
not very practical so like no not being
uh
requiring a lot of samples sometimes uh
because of you know it's randomized
nature
uh of the algorithm basically and uh
deteriorating basically the standard
performance all of these things you know
come together and you know it's it's
very far from being practically
practically usable at this point in
addition to of course not being that
robust that we want
but still open problem i'm super excited
i'm working on it all the time
in fact we are working on so like in a
couple of months
we would have like something that like
probably the the first so we would have
like a really really
good defense again at the serial patches
which is practical and
to be honest i feel this is the first
time it's going to be like people will
think actually yeah
let's probably deploy this model i'm
very very excited about this work and in
a couple of months hopefully like in our
lab we're working on this
super exciting and yeah i can't wait to
like you know open source exactly tell
the people about it but i'm very
i'm very optimistic about this so it's
specifically for adversarial patches
it's really amazing and the first time
you know like the first time i think
like the practical
the fans uh can can go out there and
like you people think
because it's like it doesn't it's very
fast it doesn't create standard
performance and
it achieves remarkable um robustness
against their patches
on imagenet scale so it's really
impressive uh i feel i'm promising so
uh we are working on it and they are
preparing it you know really well so i'm
very excited for that
but uh but yeah like most most of the
work on robustness have been you know
adversely examples have been
like on security applications which is
kind of makes sense right like it's the
first
first kind of like you know uh obvious
or like direct application
uh uh or they're direct you know like
yeah direct kind of like application
where adverse examples you know like
hurt the system so it makes sense to
work on it from a security perspective
but also like there's have there have
been you know a bunch of works uh
uh that that discussed you know
robustness and adverse robustness beyond
security
like the nice thing about address
examples in addition that to that you
know it's easy like
it's it's it's an impressive phenomenon
because it's great it breaks your model
easily you know small perturbations
breaks the model
this adversity example these adverse
examples have actually given given us
insights
about our models it turns out you know
like if you actually you know do
adversarial training
to block these adversary examples you're
kind of adding a prior on your model
which actually makes it learn a really
really robust and nice representation
that hasn't learned it before a more
human aligned representation
that that that basically aligns more
with aligns more with how humans
perceive perceive basically the world
roughly speaking so it's really like
it's really it's really like a nice
prior and in addition to like
you know being something that hurts uh
our
our models it actually can benefit like
those insights that we achieve that we
get from adversary business uh
like are really really essential for
like learning uh
learning representations and other
topics that we actually care about
and in machine learning and i think like
in this chat we're gonna focus about
like you know
two applications that that that actually
improve the performance of
of actual systems in the real world by
what
and and whose insights were brought from
address or examples basically
so you know we we look at whatever we we
did for these examples we learn from it
we we get some insights and we solve
other updates other tasks and and like
apply to other applications
which i found really really really
exciting and
as you mentioned like those applications
you know
include designing and adversary examples
um which basically reverses the story as
you said
of adversary examples so instead of like
breaking a model
by generating adversity examples you
actually design the world
in a way that the neural networks can
perceive it much much
much nicer and much better so basically
you add features to your objects
you add features that neural networks
like and really really you know
uh grasp on and i guess we will get like
into these these the these details later
on i guess
in the chat but uh but yeah
uh examples i think like were um
were key for for me to like get into it
you know to like
like to to get fundamentally into like
machine learning and like start actually
doing really really good work like when
i when i joined microsoft i remember
so i didn't do any any you know research
on adversary examples before before
joining microsoft's ai residency
so when i joined microsoft uh i remember
that
so so they're like you know you join an
ai residency you have to choose some
some some project to work on some set of
people to work on
really exciting it's like you can work
on anything you want
uh you know so you have you have
microsoft and all the microsoft
resources and all my stuff people you
can choose wherever whoever you want to
work on with
so i felt really really well like i
wanted to take that opportunity to
actually get into something that's
that's really impactful and people care
about and you know it's
it's it's actually you know like not
easy like it's it's very
you know challenging and uh you know it
was in the middle of the hype of like
you know
obviously robustness and there's your
examples and many attacks like every day
there's an attack every day there did it
and there's a defense so it's really
exciting
uh so i i i was like that's it i want to
get into this i want to like start you
know
start like i want to find the best as
everyone starts i want to i want to
solve this problem
i want to you know build the best
defense i'm going to stop adversary
examples
so i started working you know uh reading
reading a lot of papers
uh subscribing to like google scholar to
like get every single
to read every single attack and defense
which is impossible so i stopped doing
that
but uh but yeah so i started like
digging hard on like seeing what what
what problems like current defenses have
what problems
certified defenses have and then as you
mentioned uh we published the first uh
paper on like complex relaxation which
tried basically to like
uh so which is basically along a which
is basically on
your network verification or
certification so
we find we found that you know so
there's adversity examples
it's a problem people try to defend
against it in an empirical way or in a
certified way
so empirically there is basically there
there's billion ways
that people have tried but like nothing
works more than like you know doing
adversarial training
probably that's like the most effective
way just like you know
train on adversary examples and
it works decently but not as much as as
good as you want well there's a lot of
variants of it
and you'll find them with different
different names but like they're
essentially all
um doing doing similar things and
there's also certified defenses
which gives you robustness guarantees so
you have guarantees that your model is
robust
so the something that we found is that
there's like
20 papers on certified defenses
which do convex relaxation of neural
networks specifically relu networks
and they try to like you know push the
bounds push the push the certificates
that they that they get
but they are also kind of essentially
it's the same like they are
doing similar things a bit of heuristics
to like do the relaxation better
so what we did is that we just unified
all of these in one framework
and we sold this framework to optimality
so like we actually found you know like
the best bounds this this this neural
network this this
this this relaxation uh problem actually
uh can get and why that's a problem it
was a problem because it requires so
much compute like i remember we did like
150 years of cpu compute or something
that's why people didn't actually solve
the optimal problem there so we
unified everything in one framework we
solved the optimal problem and we showed
that
the optimal problem is actually really
really bad like it doesn't it doesn't
give you much
like it doesn't actually close close the
gap with like exact verifiers such as
mixed integer programming very fires for
example on even simple problems
so like why like so so we we basically
had like one simple message like
if you want to do relaxation just like
do more than layer wise convex
relaxation because if you do the right
relaxation with some approximations
you're not gonna you're not gonna get
like much from it so that was you know
like uh interesting paper and like
people liked it apparently
uh so i was i was very excited very
happy because you know people started
you know talking about it you know you
like you put it on archive you you open
source the code you
you tweet about it and then people start
interacting this is the best moment like
of of
of the research uh of the research kind
of
point like life of a student or like a
researcher i guess
at least for me i i get very excited
like you know when i i'm very excited
like
the day before i want to like to beat
unannounced it opens and open source the
the work
i'm super excited um so yeah that was
that was really nice and people liked it
i was very happy
and it was kind of a step for me like i
was always like you know i have nothing
in this field i want to do something
like i am like you know i have nothing
i haven't done anything in this field so
this was like this was like the first
step for me
will i get into this field and
immediately after we published this
paper
uh randomized smoothing came out you
know like it was like came out like two
weeks before we followed this paper or
something like that
and right now and it sounded like you
know like a very scalable method and
that that's actually promising that
that's a promising direction
and certified defenses for the fans to
defend against adversarial examples
so it's the first it's probably the
first work that actually scales to
imagenet
and it's really really like you know
theoretically
theoretically really well motivated and
really nice like has
nice theoretical kind of foundations um
so i worked with a bunch of like
theoretical computer scientists at
microsoft and
researchers like it was actually really
nice problem to work on
and what we did there is that we
basically tried to like
improve uh not the actual certification
but try to train models that are best
that are better for this meth for the
certification method
so what we did is that essentially like
how randomized moving works is that
you train a model to be able to classify
well under gaussian noise
and then you pass and you for if you
want to like certify an image
you replicate it like end times i don't
know hundred or thousand times
you add random noise to it random
gaussian noise to each to each sample
you pass them through the network
and then you take the majority vote on
that and also you can like
do something else also like to get some
some certificate of robustness like how
how like what's the radius of your l2
ball in which you are robust
so what we did is that we kind of
trained to figure out a way to train
them
the model that we use for you know
smoothing or for
randomized smalling in a better way so
we basically employed adversarial
training to optimize the right objective
so that the the cool thing there is that
we kind of approximated the
actual objective of the smooth
classifier so now we are not actually
certifying the actual classifier there's
another classifier which is wrapped
around this new classifier which does
this process of randomized smoothing so
passes in
random noisy images or noisy images
basically of your current image passes
them through a network
many many many times takes the majority
of out of these so this
this kind of like a process is a new
classifier
um so essentially to to to to
what we wanted is that to be able to
like find what the right noise that we
want to add
so that we get the best kind of model
for such process
so we did basically adversarial training
but
on the objective of this smooth
classifier so that was the contribution
there like you know
uh attacking the smooth classifier to
find adversarial examples for the smooth
classifier and train on these and it
boosts the results really really a lot
and
also people liked it so i was very very
excited so like you know
two two papers after each other and
people like them i was super excited
like
uh like i think these are the two
favorites that you know got me more
confident and like you know
more more kind of like uh you know
excited to like continue working and
like you know
uh like search more and do more stuff
on how how how to improve you know
robustness
of neural networks and uh yeah so these
are these were the first two papers i
did them during the ai residency and
then i switched to be a research
engineer
at microsoft and then continued working
on this on these on these topics so i
collaborated with the
a bunch of people so i recalibrated with
zika culture from cmu and
alexander madrid from mit who's my
advisor right now um
uh like those those were kind of like
the two of the leaders of in this field
so
i just like kind of reached out to them
and i was like you know i have this
good idea do you want to collaborate or
something like that and they're like
they were really really open to it so i
was very excited like it's really
exciting like how you can
easily you know reach the people and
like start collaborations and like i i i
actually like doing that a lot like it's
really nice
like you just reach out to them and they
are really nice people
in general so like at least zico and
alexander
are amazing both of them like they are
they were really really nice and easy
easily approachable
so i just reached out to them and
discussed started discussing with them
met them at
eurips i remember as well when i
presented these two works
it was really really exciting so i
started then like working with zico on
like this
the noise smoothing paper
uh and let me know guys if you wanna
like if i should stop or not i'm just
like saying everything i'm telling the
story of my life
no it's fine carry on sounds good all
right let's do it
so so yeah i i joined i i basically you
know i remember i discussed
like in years 2019 i met ziko like
after after a tutorial he that he gave
or like i thought he gave or something
and we i
i don't know i got this idea of like you
know why don't we
i was discussing with him and you know
we we we thought like why don't we
like like it's it we were actually
trying to like think of ways to improve
so basically the original randomized
smoothing paper came from his lab
and then you know uh me and like some
researchers at microsoft you know
improved it
or you know presented this work on like
how to train it better
so we were thinking how we can push it
more because it seemed like probably the
only method that can scale
like how can we push it more and more so
we were thinking that
all right so like our models or the my
smoothing really depends on like being
able to like
classify well under under gaussian noise
right
so why don't we kind of like add a
pre-processing step to our inputs before
passing them to a classifier
so we were trying to like append the
noise denoiser
to a classifier and train basically this
end to end
to figure out like can we actually
improve randomized smoothing and it
turned out that it doesn't help at all
you know you are just like you know
adding
you're you're just like enlarging your
model but like it's not reading it's not
really
helping helping a lot so while doing
that we were like oh
like what if we just like fix the
classifier and like you know train the
denoiser
so like what if we have a classifier
that's fixed
pre-trained black box what if we fix it
and we just
append a denoiser or pre train a pre
like some denoiser and fix
like prepended before this classifier
and then like do randomize moving on
this whole new classifier
does it actually work and it turns out
that it actually works really well
and why is this interesting is that okay
randomized winning is amazing and
it's probably one of the it's not yet
where you want it to be of course but
it's one of the only methods that work
and so so so like obviously like we want
we have to think about how to apply it
eventually how to apply it to actual you
know the
real world problems so imagine you have
you know you are using
uh google's or microsoft's or any of the
shelf
image classification api and you wanna
instead of querying it
for predictions and on google and
microsoft let's say they are lazy to
deploy their own
certified defenses because it doesn't
really work well so far so what if you
want actually to obtain some
certificates
from those small like from those models
you can literally just
wrap these models which are black box
you don't know anything about them you
can append basically
you can like append a denoiser before
them in this process of like querying
and then just like pass a bunch of noisy
images of your current image of interest
that you want to certify
and then get the prediction pass them
through the noise so add noise pass it
through your denoiser
then pass it through the api get a bunch
of predictions
take the majority of z votes of these
and that's it you have um
like you have you have you have uh
you have a prediction that's that's that
comes with a certificate as well so you
can pass
you can also like the output that you
get you can take the majority vote to
get the prediction and you can also like
you know calculate calculate the actual
certificate that you get like how robust
the model is around this data point that
you are passing
that was really really exciting like so
we did it like for we we certified like
uh google's api microsoft azure's api
uh clarify api and the aws api like it
was actually really cool to just like
you know go
there just like try see how like how
robust these models are without you know
doing this process and then how more
robust they become after you
doing this process so it was really
really cool and we possibly we published
this
at europe's as well 2020 uh i think
yeah and people liked it as well so i'm
excited
so so i like like when people like like
i really
i really invest time like writing papers
like a lot of time like
like in our lab and in my previous at
microsoft as well and
more specifically in our current lab
like we invest a lot of time in like
writing papers and like
making sure the code is really smooth
and runs and like replicable
and write a blog post like we don't open
source anything without like a code blog
post
so that people you know is like are easy
like to to like
to like see the work like it because
like there's like so much noise there's
like billion papers a day
in machine learning so if your paper is
not like really well
done like first of all the problem has
to be like you know
well motivated the writing has to be
really really nice because people
are lazy to read like if i if i start
reading a paper and like i don't
understand what's going on and like you
know it's not well written
i'm like people are lazy by nature
they're not gonna like continue writing
most pro
reading most probably so as long as you
don't like you know feed it to them like
very easily they're not gonna like
there's billion things like
they will they'll say ah let me continue
working on my code like whatever i'm
doing but like unless it's like really
well written
with a blog post with like easily you
know people like when they understand
stuff
that's my that's my understanding like
when they people you know you know when
you tell something about people and they
understand it
they like it and they get motivated and
they then they start following your work
and like
uh hopefully building on top of it so
that we you know improve
the state of the art of like ai and like
science in general
so like i feel this is really nice
something nice about machine learning
that you know people try
to like you know make things applicable
and
and you know easily easily doable and
like you don't see like very complicated
papers you
you see chunks of papers which is really
nice actually and uh so yeah
in short like i try to expend so much
time on to to like make the papers
really really well
uh well written so i so so of course i
feel sad
if after this all work you know people
that don't like like it or like
you know i don't know if it doesn't you
know get a lot of attention
it feels a little bit sad but it's fine
like it's worth that at least you see
you feel you know you have
um you have done you know your part and
then it's up to people to like it or not
or
to appreciate it uh or you know but like
i really spend time also like choosing
what problems to work on because there's
many many problems you can work on so
i spent time optimizing because any
problem you get into if it's tiny or if
it's big
it's gonna take you a few months to like
try the paper write the code etc
so you better spend this time on like
problems like you better spend like
two weeks thinking not doing anything
and then like
like start actually you know like
working on the problem then like
starting immediately on a very s
tiny idea that you get which might not
you know be that impactful
because anyway it's gonna take like
three months four months from you to
like write the paper you know write the
code etc
if you want to do it well of course if
you don't want to do it well it's easy
you can just like write it overnight
but but yeah it's it's exciting when
people you know
like the work and you know appreciate it
and start interacting with it and
building on top of it
it's really satisfying for a researcher
at least for me i don't know for
everyone but i get this for me it's very
very satisfying
so after this um all right so i think
this is probably
yeah so after this i so i i don't know
how
things happen exactly but like we
started
i started celebrating you know uh like
me and
some researchers at microsoft circle
everything with alexander madhuri
as well so we were starting discuss
discussing like we wanted like to
actually you know like
uh see like where we can where we can go
also like with robustness and
it was after you know this adverse
robustness uh like features are not bugs
you know
uh sorry like uh at least examples are
not bugs they are features
uh paper it is really inspiring and it
came up with it came out with like two
other papers which like show that
you can actually use robustness and to
do to do other tasks so this was really
really
inspiring for me and it was really
amazing well written
uh like really nice experiments nice
motivating
i think they're like the crucial thing
is that like the set of experiments that
delivered this idea
uh uh it was really nice really really
nice
so i started thinking like how how how
we can push forward like
i don't know how like how i start
thinking about stuff but like i don't
know exactly how i
what i did exactly but like i started
thinking like how can we
push this more how can what like is this
it all like
what what does it mean that there's
another bus features robust features
what can we do with these
what does it mean that you know uh if
you train with adversarial training
you get you know a nice representation
so like if it's nice looking guess what
like so what like what
what happens um so so we got this idea
of like okay so it's we
when we actually do addressable training
we we are kind of like blocking these
non-robust features and keeping those
robust features right so like in the
robust features model they're like every
feature presentation is like this
divided into like robust and robust
features
so by doing additional training you are
kind of like masking the non-robust
features keeping the robust features
only
right and when you do that you get like
nice nice representations
in the sense that so a direct
application for that was like
what does like okay a very important
place where we care about feature
representation is like for transfer
learning
we basically have you know those source
models that we train on large data sets
and we have some small tasks where we do
not have much data or compute
and we want to basically transfer the
knowledge that we learned unlock those
huge tasks such as image net for example
or other other more larger tasks
and you want to transfer train models
there transfer them to work on
very quickly on those small tasks
imagine you are working in a company
you have you are doing grasping or
something and you have like your own
data set
of like i don't know 1000 images and you
want to create a model in that good luck
trading from scratch
so it's better like that you boost strap
your model by
starting from pre-trained pre-trained
model and then fine-tune that on your
small data set
what decides how well you're going to do
one thing that decides how well you're
going to do is the quality of the
features that you're transferring over
so really you know the features that
your source model learn
are crucial because you are transferring
them basically and then fine tuning on
the on the on the target model
um but what does like what does so we're
thinking like what does like how
how do we decide what these features are
and in general these features are
dictated by what priors we
use or add to the training process when
we actually know our training
so this this includes the losses we use
the regularizers we use like if you if
you do some regularizer you are actually
you know
adding some like inductive bias and
you're advising the model to like you
know prefer
like to to to kind of like eliminate
some some some
some weird things that he does that
doesn't have to learn and learn some
other stuff
and this includes also like you know any
data augmentation you do uh
the optimizers you use anything
basically that you actually like choices
that you do during training
uh adds some bias you know like and and
and shapes your features basically
you know so your features that you learn
basically depends on what priorities you
have so we're thinking okay what happens
if we do address your business
so this is an additional prior right
like you are you are forcing the model
basically if given two images that are
very visually similar
you want it to output the same
predictions so those images were
basically can be basically
shifted by some non-robust features
which are the adversarial examples or
like that
adversarial perturbations but both of
them you want them to be
predicted similarly by the network which
is something you know
that makes sense like we want our models
if given to visually similar images
to output the same thing uh so
we were thinking like what happens if we
add this robustness prior so what we did
is we did it
like we started training we trained a
bunch of image net robust models robust
imaginative models
and standard legitimate models then we
transferred the representations learned
to 12 different image classification
tasks but
before coming there actually like there
was there are some conflicting evidence
of like
why this this might might not actually
work because like whenever we train with
robust training
we actually deteriorate the standard
performance of the model
and there is a paper by google by
cornbread al that showed that
in order to get better transfer learning
your source models have to be better so
better event models transfer better so
they showed that there is a correlation
with how well your imagenet model
is achieving on imagenet with how well
it's going to transfer to a wide range
of trans of of of downstream tasks
so this was okay okay we were like okay
damn it then this might not probably
work
because our robust models have lower
accuracies but let's try it anyway
you know let's see maybe maybe maybe we
find something interesting and indeed it
was interesting that you know those
robust models when we transfer them
although they have lower accuracies than
the standard models they transfer better
consistently on a wide range of tasks
not only image classification but also
object detection and instant
segmentation
it was really surprising really nice
really clean really like you know direct
like i like when
i like when when when when when these
the results they come you know the idea
is very simple etc and
the the results just flow immediately
you don't have to do any hacks anything
just like you know it works i love when
this happens like it's really satisfying
as well
for me so so so yeah
we just created a bunch of robust models
bunch of non-robust uh standard models
the robust models transfer better so we
started thinking why this is the case
like is that conflicting evidence like
what's going on like what
we are we have lower accuracies how like
what happens with the google paper like
you know
what did they find there so we actually
dig more and we found that
in in it actually is the like of course
the google paper is correct like you
know
uh we find that we are not like you know
we didn't say that it's not correct but
we
wanted to understand what's going on uh
so we found that both robustness and
accuracy
uh are important so if at a fixed
robustness level
if you increase the accuracy of the
model you improve
transfer learning so what we what we got
is basically kind of like a
a correlation curve between image net
accuracy and transfer accuracy that's
basically higher than the standard model
for robust models
so what what essentially that means that
is that if you improve the robustness
all the shift all all the kind of like
transfer like translating curve that
basically relates you know how large the
model is or how well it's performing on
imagenet
and how well it's gonna transfer shifts
up um so it was really
really exciting so just for best
transfer
so so for best transfer learning
performance
you need both that's a robustness and
accuracy so if you fix robustness level
and increase accuracy you increase
performance so
it's so so what the paper what the
google paper found is that
at a business level of zero basically if
you fix if you're improving
so so that paper should be basically
better image net models transferred
better at a fixed robustness level or
something like that
so like if you fix the resonance level
you improve the image that model yes it
transfers better
but that's like that's kind of like for
a fixed robustness
but if you improve robustness it will it
even if the accuracy is lower it might
transfer better
but uh and and that people got an oral
actually at like in europe's i was super
excited like
this was you know like one of one of my
previous papers you know the
the randomized smoothing one got a
spotlight so it was my second paper in
this video so i was very excited as well
like i was super super excited then but
like the oral one i was like
damn it like that's amazing i was like i
was like in redmond
of course at home you know enjoying the
pandemic from home
uh and suddenly you received this email
it was really really amazing i was like
oh okay
like that okay my goal not my goal but
like i would like to
eventually to get some best paper award
or something but like getting an order
before starting my phd was like
amazing i was like okay this is great so
i was very very very excited
i don't know people some people don't
care about like you know awards and
stuff but me at least as a young
researcher
you know just starting this motivates me
a lot like you know
it's in addition to like what people
appreciate how impactful the work is it
actually gets like you know some nice
award like no
appreciation at the conference it's it's
it's really nice
i know this doesn't matter a lot maybe
like you know it's just like like
something like
but at least for me it motivates me and
that's what's important for me
so so so that's good uh so yeah people
liked it as well
super exciting uh can i can i maybe jump
in here
uh for for a moment and talk about this
because it this is it's very interesting
right the fact that
you get more robust models and they
transfer
better and so
you know on one hand you can make the
argument that
the representation of robust models is
better
just because of the fact of how we train
them
but isn't it also the case that this
might be an effect of how we define
what transfer learning is because in
transfer learning
you know we we define the objectives for
which means that you know we as humans
we think
these two tasks are somewhat close right
like these are medical images
these are imagenet images right to make
the determination
which tasks are even considered transfer
learning tasks
we use our human assessment of
the data which is exactly
the what you would call a robust
features
right so to even make the determination
of which tasks are transfer learning
tasks
we use robust features and
when you train robust models you exactly
train them to be
responsive to robust features so what i
would
have maybe as a bit of a challenge
hypothesis is that
maybe these models don't actually
transfer better
to any transfer learning task but only
to the transfer learning test that we as
humans consider
uh to be transfer learning tasks there
might be
there might be other tasks to which the
non-robust models transfer much better
but we just don't we don't know because
we never try
like okay here i have my malware
detection
data set how am i supposed to know that
my imagenet model is going to transfer
really well
i just don't get the idea right because
i'm a human
so is is this is this kind of a this
seems like a bit of a circular
loop of how we define the task and then
you know how we solve it
i mean it's cool but yeah
yeah no this is this is is it not an
anti-pattern because
why would i use an imagenet model for a
malware classification task because it's
effectively
going to result into negative transfer
right because the overlap between my
source dataset and target dataset is
roughly various parts but that's what
you're saying right i'm that that's what
you think
what i'm no no no of course of course
you're right you're right like
i'm more making kind of an esoteric
point that
you know there essentially and i agree i
agree with you hoddy this paper
like the features not box paper i
consider like a landmark paper
in in the literature of adversarial
examples
it clearly like the experiments are very
convincing about the fact that
you know that the data contains features
that to us humans
seem like yeah those are features right
like shape and whatnot
but they also contain features that
we don't care about as humans but
they're still features
and now what i'm what i'm saying is that
you know when we as humans come up with
a transfer learning task we say look
these two things have much
overlap and we do this on the basis of
robust features
however there might be there might be
two tasks
that we as humans think have no overlap
like the malware thing so as a human we
think
now what do they have in common but
right it could be
that they share the same uh non-robust
features
yeah no i i actually i actually totally
like this is a great point to be honest
okay there's a bunch of things here that
i wanna discuss it's actually really
really a subtle point
in fact like very recently there's a
paper that came out that showed that
actually this correlation doesn't happen
if you transfer from imagenet
to like chexnet so you know medical
image it doesn't it probably doesn't
have any overlap it's
just using like some like weird features
that you know that are not existing
maybe there are existing
that has none robust features but like
otherwise features as
for humans nothing overlaps you know but
maybe maybe
maybe there are some non robust features
which transfer
and which is which is great and that's
why probably you see a little bit of
improvement from
imagenet to uh chexnet
but this correlation and this this
hasn't been done on robust like if you
train it if you transfer robust model to
checksnap
so pro i actually was trying to try that
to be honest like i was trying to like
see because after this like
someone tweeted about it like the
i forget i'm bad at names oh my god i
forget someone to tweet about this paper
about like transferring from internet to
the chex net and they show that you know
this google paper doesn't hold like if
you actually improve
image that model you know on imagenet
it doesn't transfer better or checks net
they always all they all roughly get the
same performance
so you are just like you know
transferring some minimal minimal
knowledge there
so personally i wouldn't i wouldn't tend
to like
i mean people you know whenever they do
medical imaging they just start from
internet pre-training
i don't know why but like it doesn't
help that much it helps a little bit
and this correlation doesn't hold but i
totally agree you might actually you
know
uh trans try to transfer a robust model
and it doesn't
improve better than standard models
maybe if to it's worse i don't know but
i i was actually
trying to try that but regarding this
point of like
what what what like what what's
transferring like this
there are robust enormous features like
what's going on i don't know exactly
what
i don't know the exact answer to this
but like i have a hypothesis which is
basically
okay you have this robust features and
non-robust features when you are doing
robust training
you are just masking blocking out the
non-robust features of imagenet
which are you know like kind of
shortcuts that imagenet model on image
learns only on imagenet like there are
tiny things that are specific to
imagenet
so robust features are probably more
transferable like they have those shapes
and stuff
so by blocking these kind of like
non-robust features and transferring the
robust ones and then fine tuning on the
new task we are
just like filling in the gaps the
non-robust features of the new task
that's how i see it to be honest can i
ask some dumb questions right real quick
yeah the thing is i feel like this is
this is quite an advanced conversation
and i need to dumb it down a little bit
so
when when your lab released the features
not bugs paper
it made the quite interesting finding as
i understand that
the vulnerability here to adversarial
examples is a function of the data set
itself and it spoke about
this dichotomy between robust features
and non-robust features
and if i understand correctly non-robust
features are basically
features that generalize quite well but
are imperceptible to humans so
a robust speed feature might be a pig
snout
and a non-robust feature might just be
some weird collection of pixels that
unfortunately generalizes very well
very well indeed so it seemed to explain
this phenomenon that there's the
transferability
of these features is is because it's in
the data then that's why
it affects so many different types of
models now the the paper did an
experiment didn't it to kind of
um let's see what happens if we remove
the non-robust features from the data
set why don't we just start with that
how the hell did they actually do that
so so they did two experiments in that
paper i wasn't on in the lab when they
did that but i know the paper
so the first experiment basically is
that they they they just try to like you
know
the first uh so they did two experiments
let me remember them so the first one
was
uh just kind of like for for a data set
of dogs and cats
just like you know fine adversary
examples for dogs and these are examples
for
cats and then you have your set of
examples and label them different
basically the the the images that are
labeled as dogs
has the non-robust features of cats and
then the images that are labeled as
cats has the anonymous features of dogs
so just like you know
use relabel these images to be cats
where there are non-robust features
but the actual image for humans is a dog
and dogs where there are numerous
features of dogs but the actual image is
a cat and train on those
and then you achieve really really high
accuracy there so
so so like you still which which says
that you know those numbers features
very high accuracy on the original test
set right that that's what's crazy so
so you give the model like a data set of
a bunch of dogs which are all labeled
cat right
but you've perturbed them to
adversarially look to the model like a
cat
and now that model trained on this data
set
will be able to recognize a true cat
image from the original test set which
which like
unequivocally tells you that there's
something in these images
that it can use to to actually recognize
cats
yeah exactly so so this first experiment
yeah just said that you know those
you can act you can just generalize from
this these numbers features
so the other experiment was basically uh
trying to just remove those thunderbolts
features from the data set
and train using standard training on
this new data set that's robustified
so it has basically no non-robust
features
and then you achieve you know robust
accuracy by just like you know doing
standard training
but i suppose um philosophically though
what's the difference but
you know we've got robust features which
are human perceptible features and we've
got non-robust features
does it really matter it's the first
question and the second question
is um we were talking with francois
charles last week about the manifold
hypothesis you know he has this
beautiful idea that
all natural data falls on this
interpretable manifold
and presumably all of these different
types of features fall on
different manifolds do they yeah yeah no
i
i actually i actually quite believe with
this kind of like you know uh
conjecture hypothesis uh like yeah like
like i feel like this manifold is
basically i mean it's it's easily
describable for by humans but like not
mathematically and rigorously
you know formulated like describe like
the way we describe this metaphor is
basically
the manifold of images which human
actually recognize as you know
like correct images and that makes sense
basically but i feel you know those
those images of the cat that are that
have the numbers features of dogs
these are you know i agree with that
like they are on totally different
manifold and
as because as a human this manifold of
like human
you know uh making sense images i don't
know what you what do i call that
manifold
so so a human when he sees or she sees
the image of a dog that has none of us
features of the cat
they will say this is a dog there is no
way they will figure out that this is a
cat
so i totally agree with this uh i i mean
i don't know how to prove it but i i
don't i totally agree with this i i feel
like you know this is this is
this is what's what's going on and in
practice okay
like like no one knows exactly like
what's like what's like
even though there was features model
it's just like a model it's like i'm not
like
in 100 this is the case like no one
actually knows exactly what's going on
but i could like i feel like these non
robust features and anonymous features
you know separation
inspires you to do a lot of like cool
stuff
downstream tasks try to justify what's
going on
and uh you know like similar to transfer
learning you try to like justify why
transfer learning works
like what's going on are we transferring
the non-robust features or the robust
features
and you know like like all of these like
interplay between like what robust
features and
what features mean that you did inside
the
do adversarial robustness help in
transfer learning i'm sorry if i forgot
the exact name of the paper but
in that paper you showed that if you
have better norm separation
i mean norm separation has some kind of
relationship
with you know fine-grained features or
coarser
grain features and so on do you think
maybe this
might have been the case for non-robust
as opposed to
uh robust features uh you me but by what
like you mean the the
the size like how robust your your model
is like the like the basically the size
of the
like the size of the lp ball that you're
training yeah maybe the robust features
are actually helping
into the norm separation and that's why
maybe they are able to distinguish
better because this is one of the
hypothesis that you have already shown
in the paper so maybe you could
you know take that route we don't like
we don't show anything like we don't we
don't like show that this is
actually like we just like you know
hypothesize we cannot like there's
there's no proofs but it's just like
running like no empirical uh experiments
but uh uh but yeah like i think okay the
people
we try to have like to avoid like having
you know getting into conclusions oh we
are transferring the robust features
and we are not like like transferring
the non-robust features or something
like that because
i don't know if that's exactly the case
like but
but but intuitively the way i think
about because definitely more work has
to be done there to like see like what's
exactly going on but what i can tell you
is that
really like okay the way i think about
it is
just we are blocking kind of the
non-robust features which are
generalized it's they are good to
generalize but like for the same
distribution
images from the same distribution but
they are tough to generalize
to images from other distributions
that's my intuition to be honest
so that's why we're trying to block them
so that they don't interfere in
during fine tuning on this task at
target sorry yeah target task basically
we're just like eliminating them could
you spell it out to me because i still
don't completely understand that
i was so confused about this the first
time that yannick explained it to me
because he said
there are robust features and non-robust
features but the definition
does not seem to include generalization
right
we all accept that generalization in
deep learning
is a function of interpolation on a
manifold
right and non-robust features apparently
have the feature that they do generalize
so they do fall on another manifold
and there must be some differences
between these manifolds if because we're
talking about robustness and brittleness
and accuracy and there's an interesting
interplay between them right so you're
saying that the non-robust features
maybe they're less learnable
maybe the manifold is different maybe
the manifold has discontinuities maybe
it's less interpretable
but you know are you saying that the
non-robust features generalize
worse than the robust features
um i cannot definitely say but i i would
say from
from this you know transfer learning
experiment i believe so
because you know like if you keep them
and then you transfer okay
there's there's one experiment that i
wanted to do but like i never did i'll
tell you about it that
that can that might actually answer that
exactly
so so okay so the way i think about it
is that because we are blocking them
okay when
we don't block these features and
transfer you know robust and robust
features
we get like some some like improvement
on like downstream tasks above of
transfer trading from scratch
but when we block them and keep only the
robust features we get better
better better performance there so the
actual interesting experiment is
to try to transfer just like the
underwater features just like you know
create this data set with non-robust
features and
train a model on that and then transfer
that and then create a data set with
only the robust features so a
robustified imagenet
dataset which has only robust features
and try to transfer that
and then in unrobust they imagine a
dataset which has wrong
visually looking images but like has the
non-robust features there
and try to transfer that and that kind
of might actually you know
like kind of like okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna do this i'm gonna like
let's see that comes back to exactly the
point that i was making
in the fact that what i i think
what we call transfer learning is a
function of the robust features
like the the way we even select the task
so i think the
as you amend the paper name that what it
should be i think it should be even
amended more
saying that you know uh robust robust
features
help for generalization four
tasks that a robust featurer as humans
considers to be transfer learning or
help for
sorry help for transactions so i guess
that also a question would be is
can we find equally many tasks for which
the non-robust features
transfer learn even though we wouldn't
consider them transfer learning tasks or
are they actually let's say useless um
but yeah sorry to to tim's to tim's
point maybe i got asked an interesting
question
yesterday that might clarify this a
little bit uh so
someone uh asked me in
in my phd exam actually um
isn't if if you think about language and
you think about
the question how many legs does a snake
have
right and you type that into google for
questions like this
google will often give you an answer and
it will be like a number
that it finds somewhere right and now
imagine why that is that is because
these question answering systems they've
been trained
on kind of questions with marked answers
now you consider and now
consider what the model does the model
sees how many
so the model is like super duper primed
to find some number
somewhere because in all the training
data set whenever it was how many
the answer is some number but now you
add
snake which and so in the training data
it has never seen those two features
it has seen snake it has seen how many
but never
correlated like never together right so
now it's sort of it
it it focuses on the one with the
stronger signal but what you've
essentially done is
you've kind of ripped two features that
shouldn't be together
you've put them together and the same
goes sort of for
for these these images so
never ever in the data set is there a
dog
shape with like the microstructure of a
cat
fur right yet that's exactly what you do
when you create an adversarial example
you create a picture with a dog shape
and a cat's micro fur structure
now the model you know being a cnn being
very
you know being very acute to
the structure to like little features
it sees that and it's confused but it
goes with the one that gives it a
stronger signal
which is what we call the non-robust
features
yet still all the cats have that so that
that
that is a good feature right but we just
put it
in very weird constellations there's an
interesting thing there
right which is that does non-robust
imply low magnitude right because
because you because the interesting
thing is that the cnn has this weird
entanglement
wouldn't it be wonderful if you could
say well snakes don't have fur i've
never seen that before well actually
they get entangled together so you can't
ask the question so like
what exactly do you mean by low
magnitude as in
the pixel map you don't need to change
the pixel mass much
to make that feature file but there's no
good way to capture that
like actually mathematically so a lot of
things have been tried like let's say
oh they're just high frequency features
we'll just do like a low pass filter
right
like nah doesn't doesn't work right oh
they're they're not
yeah that doesn't work yeah or like just
like
i mean try to denoise the image or
something no no this doesn't work uh
like it's just like you know hit that
like think about it as yes i mean they
are you know like tiny features
and high frequency ones but like hidden
like in very very high dimensions like
you know you have
imagine like you have like a hyper cube
of like you know many many many blocks
around you
and if you are just like adding random
noise i'm like trying to like you know
like if you like basically trying to
like you know remove the
the bombs from around you basically
you're just like randomly choosing like
a bunch of these
boxes but like you cannot actually it's
very difficult to find the one that
actually has this you know
you know like small perturbations just
like there's exponentially many
boxes around you and this is like
hypercube so it's really really tough
like
i don't i like like that and like that
sorry like
regarding this kind of example like the
only way like we currently have
know how to do like where very well is
like adversarial training so trying to
like you know
follow what this like attacker did like
to place this kind of like
example in this cube or randomize
smoothing which basically tries to like
you know
remove everything from around you and
all the cubes but this deteriorates your
performance because you are just
smoothing a lot you are just like you
know making your function less is
expressive so i guess it's easy to say
that models do latch into high frequency
spurious correlations but it's
still ill understood as to why that's
the case i mean there are some fourier
analysis
uh i mean fourier perspective on
robustness of vision models but
it's still pretty understood in my
opinion i guess
it's also one of the reasons hendrix and
their lab
came out with the paper on natural
adversarial examples i mean examples
that are naturally adversarial what can
you
do about it i mean yeah many reasons
they
laid out in that paper is one of the
reasons is texture bias-ness and stuff
and the second is that in image
classification problems multiple objects
get mapped to
discrete individual categories so this
is
also one of the reasons so i don't know
yet
but i guess there could be some
developments around these areas as to
how they correlate to you know
robustness and similar aspects of a
vision model so
i'm looking forward to such developments
maybe don't know i can also work on them
yeah this is this is a this is pretty
cool yeah um
yeah i don't know i don't know what the
solution is like but yeah there's many
many like things
we can try but yeah it's tough it's what
i can say like that's not the only thing
that i can like hundred percent i'm sure
about is that it's a tough
tough problem very tough problem but
yeah like this this this question sorry
like
this question of like nanobus robust
features is always like you know in my
head when i'm like thinking
it's just like you know like what's
going on what's transferring what's not
transferring uh how can we use them
uh what exactly are these like we have
some evidence that you know they are
actually you know like
data like they are you know a
characteristic of the data but we're not
sure about that as well still like
robustness uh the box paper
shows that like no no no like no
guarantees
that this is the case maybe it's
something this with something else
uh but yeah this this experiment of like
figuring out what exactly is
transferring
by just like training on a robust defied
image that model and transferring that
versus training on an unrobustified
imagenet model and transferring that
basically by by like flipping the labels
and like adding additional examples
is something interesting i feel like i
will i will i will do it
i like to to support this and more and
being able to answer the question
uh better because i i don't know how to
answer it right now and i can speculate
but uh
with experiments we can actually we can
like precisely uh try to like you know
get more intuition and answer these
questions
so i think the question is question of
robustness is
on one hand you want to let's say become
robust to adversarial examples but
adversarial examples
they are defined in a very specific way
if you really want to work with them
because they are defined in let's say
you know i can't perturb
by some like i have to stay within some
l infinity ball or some l2 ball around
a data point that i have in my in my
data set
and and that's how we measure kind of
closeness because we
we know very probably to a human
there's nothing in like a tiny l
infinity ball that looks different
however what we actually want to do
is to say look these two things they
seem similar to a human
right um which is completely different
from being close in
in l2 space or in l infinity space
so there's this it seems like there's
this mismatch
of you know what's close to a human and
what's close in the adversarial
example literature so my question is do
you think the ultimate solution
if we had somehow an accurate model of
the human visual system
would that help us to battle these
adversarial examples or
would we still sort of be in the same
troubles just with kind of a different
distance metric
no i do like i think like the key to
solve deep learning is figuring out this
like
close or distance metric that makes
sense like if we find that like
if we know that y two images like how to
measure two images closeness in like the
human sense we can just like use a k n
or something to just like classify we're
done that's it like you just like you
know
you run a k nano like the all images one
is neighbor that's it
done i mean all like yeah learning is
just a distance function at the end of
the day
exactly so like like that like if you if
you find this if you if you find this
business let's chat on offline and
publish the paper
and be you know legends but yeah no i
think this is uh this is the this is uh
this is the question of the day in my
opinion the way i think about it this is
the question like how what's for me for
for computer vision also i don't like
work on other like computer versions i
i'm once
i'm most motivated by computer vision uh
but yeah like for computer vision i
think the distance like similarity kind
of notion
is key to like solving many things the
more we
try to move away from the distance with
stuff i guess
we might be able to increase the
transferability
of the you know robust models because
there's also an aspect of
transferability of this robust models to
different kind of attacks right and
they do not transfer well we do have
evidence about that right until
soil phase is lab came out with a cool
technique that is based on
lp ips learn perceptual image patch
similarities that that is based on
perceptibility of you know different
robust features and
it does not rely that much on distance
based matrix
and they do show that they have better
transferability
across different attacks so i guess this
this is suggestive of the fact that the
more we try to move away from different
distance
best matrix the better we might be able
to solve the
transferability problem across different
attacks that are both
lp based and non-np-based so so the
transferability of what exactly like
adversaries attacks let's say i have
trained to train the model
that is good to defend lp based attacks
but
that again fails on non-lp attacks so
this is again
this is probably happening because we
are relying too much on distance based
matrix
maybe if we rely more on the you know
perceptible
aspects of these models maybe we can get
away with this
so but so i mean yeah like that would be
another notion of distance but like the
current notions of this the current
mathematical notions of distance are
not sufficient uh because they are are
we try we try to like just like you know
go in like certain directions or like
off of the the
image manifold or like you know space of
images
yeah but uh it's still like you know
perceptually similar images like you can
you can
you should hopefully we should be able
to define some some notion of this i
guess i wanted to
say that the conventional distance based
matrix
might fail this but yeah i mean fed is
level again
prove that perceptibility might you know
uh enhance the transferability so
yep so while we're on on the topic of of
of distances
um you you also worked quite a bit on on
certifiability
uh right i don't know what that has to
do with distances
it sounded cool in my head um
so in can you can you maybe uh just
explain a little bit for people who have
never
you know come across you know certifying
certified robustness and so on what that
actually
means because it seems quite you know
daunting to say look here is a neural
network
it's provably robust like what does that
what does that even because i i feel
it's it's kind of important that we have
a notion that you know is understandable
here
yeah and just to add on to that question
you you said that you
um you you made an add-on essentially to
let's say google's vision and
and um the the microsoft vision api and
so on
uh doing the um the randomized smoothing
and a denoising
model and you didn't even need to change
the the base classifier and i was
thinking to myself well if it's so easy
to do that why did why haven't they done
that already
so what what what yeah what does
certification mean and why haven't they
already done it
yeah no these are all great questions so
okay
certification okay so we're defending
neural networks there are two things
right like we can do like empirical
defenses
and certify differences certification is
like basically like another like
certified defense like it's like what we
get from certified defenses
so what we do for empirical defense is
that we try to like attack the model and
like train on whatever we attack so that
we get like
empirical robustness and what that means
is that there is no guarantee that you
know in
for this image we cannot find an attack
so it's just as like our robustness is
as good as the best attack
in the world so we there might be some
very super strong attack that we haven't
evaluated our
model on that can break it so that's the
problem with like empirical defenses
you're always like oh maybe you know
there's some
new attack that i don't know about so
for certification and certified defenses
you actually find a proof that around
this data point
if you perturb any kind of perturbation
around this data point within like some
you know
in uh neighborhood of the city point
whether it was like an lp ball or like
you know some other
neighborhood mathematically described
you will never be able to like flip the
prediction of the model
and the way there are many ways to do
that some people do like lp relaxation
so you just like
pass in a box around the data point
through the neural network
and then you would look at like kind of
like the polytope of like
that you get in the output of the neural
network and you check if that polytope
kind of
intersects with the the with the with
the with the with lick with kind of like
the
decision boundaries uh of your decision
of your output basically
if interest if it intersects then you
you are not certified if it doesn't
intersect then you have certificate
so you try to see like how much you can
increase this
uh ball in the input space so that you
uh get a polytope basically
like a random like a like a very
complicated shape
uh in the output which is not which
which is probably non-complex
or oh no actually it's complex because
that's what people actually do like they
do convex relaxation so that it's convex
and then you try to like see how much
you can increase the the ball in the
input space so that you
that polytope doesn't intersect
basically just i understand so you're
you're dealing with an input space let's
say
100 000 dimensions and inside there
there's some natural image manifold
maybe but
you know yeah and how could you possibly
cover all of that experience space and
do any kind of analysis about you know
yeah no in this example so
so so so you literally uh have like a
hypercube
let's say al infinity okay let's just
think at infinity you have a hypercube
basically around that data point so you
pass every kind of like
uh like like let's let's let's think in
2d
you have a square around this data point
and you want to pass this square you
know
you basically pass the boundaries of it
and you see where those boundaries
transfer because it's like a convex
mapping
the boundary transfer basically to like
you know boundaries basically in the
output space
and you will get like a convex shape
that's mo that's morphed so that's how
basically you like you you you achieve
that
you can cover everything you you're just
passing literally
trying to like see how the shape deforms
until you reach the output so
the problem comes in from the
non-linearities right
so if if we're just so that it's easy to
pass a square
through the linear layer right it will
become
maybe a square maybe you know like uh
some kind of deformed square or
something like this it will still be
convex and and the good part about this
is that
you can pass it through the next layer
again and all you have to do is you can
consider the boundaries
of the shape because everything else is
inside so everything that was inside
before
will still be inside after when you have
the non-linearities right
exactly that's when you get the weird
shapes so you can no longer say
that anything that's kind of in between
two
corners is also going to be inside the
shape right
so what people do is they they pass it
through the linear layer right they have
that chip
then they pass it through the
non-linearities and then they ask
themselves okay what's kind of the worst
case
that can happen and then they make a
convex shape
around the new thing and that's where
the the looseness of most of these
bounds come in right so
that's what you said at the very
beginning if you just do this
layer by layer you these bounds they get
so
loose that you know that the amount of
space you can certify you know where you
can say
around this image you can't find any
adversarial example it becomes like
tiny um so
i feel exactly yeah this literature is
perfect
it's not really there yet but you know
with with
things like these randomized smoothings
and so on i think we make a lot of
progress
but again i'm asking the dumb questions
here so i understand that for a given
example
in experience space you put it through
the model and as janet was saying
because of the non-linearities it
what we want to happen is that on the
other side of the neural network it will
still be a convex
um continuous mapping right so your
square on the input has been transformed
into some
beautiful little region on your manifold
and you can see within that region
whether you are
transgressing any of the decision
boundaries but my my question was
that's just one example in this hundred
thousand dimensional space so what are
you gonna do you're just gonna like
randomly sample
oh like it's similar to like how how we
evaluate like our models
like like this this this kind of like
question transfer
like goes to like okay if you train a
model on this data set and you test it
on your
test set you get some like notion of
accuracy but you didn't test on every
single example in the world
you just like test on like some held out
set to tell to see like how well
roughly you know your model will work
exactly the same for certified defenses
you just like bring a test set and test
basically you know
around each of these points how much you
can go larger and larger and then you
get a notion of like how well your model
is done
but like the problems that transfer from
evaluating image that
like machine learning models transfer to
this kind of like
setting it's just like you are getting a
sense of like how robust it is you
cannot guarantee that it's robust
it's like you are getting like local
robustness around each data point and
you evaluate it on like you know
a data set and you you you essentially
take like kind of like the
minimum uh ball and basically say
oh within this ball there's or like you
check
okay you fix the ball and you check how
many of these examples were certified
of your data set you so you say within
this ball 60
70 80 of my test set examples were
certified
that make that makes sense but i think
the the reason why microsoft then
haven't certified their vision
classifier is
the certification tells you more about
the test set you use than the actual
model so
let's say a whole bunch of my test
images they might be projected on to
a manifold and inside that manifold it's
actually very interpretable and very
smooth and has quite
good generalization capability and there
is no transgression on the decision
boundaries
whereas um you know let's say 20 of that
data actually went on to some other
not even a manifold maybe those examples
were very difficult to classify so they
were just memorized by by the model
but you wouldn't be able to do that
across the board yeah that that
i mean that that is one explanation why
they didn't do it but like i mean the
main reason
is that it doesn't yet like we get the
deterioration in standard accuracy like
randomized moving is not like you know
a working certified defense that we can
just deploy right now
it's not like at that stage at some
point hopefully it will be i don't know
maybe maybe not i don't know but at
current like currently like why though
like
why i did you know like why i tried you
know certifying these like google's api
et cetera like microsoft's uh
azures uh sorry like aws etc they didn't
do it
because they don't want to deploy a
model that is robust slightly
you know but loses accuracy like at this
point because
attackers can just like attack like they
will if if someone wants to attack you
they will be able to attack you
so you you better deploy the best model
that you can deploy
like the best performer on the average
case and like not worry about the worst
case
at this moment of time because the worst
case unless unless you have like
a model that's robust and doesn't
deteriorate your standard performance
yeah which is which is coming very very
soon in
in the paper that i thought that i
publish soon on adversarial patches
hopefully yeah hopefully hopefully i
don't find the bug from now to them
but it's looking really really good and
it's certified that's why i'm confident
it's certified so i'm not worried that
nicholas carlini will come and like
butcher
but you're still gonna do it because he
will still do it
because i wanted to come back he has to
fight with the mathematics if you want
to
i wanted to come back to carlini and
trey murray tower that we spoke to last
time so
because they they were being incredibly
down beat about this we had a good chat
with them and i just felt
demoralized afterwards yeah my god um
you know because
carlini has systematically dismantled
every single
uh adversarial attack going and you know
they
they also agreed with you they said well
it's not worth losing 10
accuracy for a bit more robustness and
his argument was that there's an
infinitude of you know more adversarial
attacks anyway so it seems like a
slightly
pointless exercise but but they said you
know the main defense mechanisms were
data augmentation
or adding more data although the more
data you add the more adversarial
examples you have and
um adversarial training i wanted to get
your take on this but also randomized
smoothing they they agreed that that was
a successful mechanism but their general
kind of take though was that we're on
the road to nowhere we are just
completely screwed when it comes to
adversarial examples
um yeah like i kind of care
i kind of agree with that i mean i agree
with that like it's
it's so tough it's so tough that like
like our best like model achieves i
don't know 60 7 60
on c410 like in some like lp lp ball so
like even
if even if we achieve like i don't know
like 90 or something like
if someone wants to attack it like they
have just like to know to
repeat the attack like 10 times or like
whatever so that they break it
or like you know like they have to
repeat it at some like
some number of times to break them all
unless it's it's like you know 100
certifiable defense and then they won't
be able to break it
but uh but i think like
like i think the key the key point is
figuring out how like
how to like make models do things
similar to humans like that's key
that's like like like i don't like i
mean i work on like robustness and
defenses and stuff but like
i also like try to like think like what
what those representations mean like how
can we make our models like do things
similar to humans
like have the prayers that humans have
like we don't like we will not be able
to fool with like being full with like
those perturbations
there are some other stuff that fools us
of course of course you know like uh
um like illusions and stuff yes which is
great i mean i'm happy if a car gets
like
uh fooled by an illusion not by like you
know tiny marker on a stop sign or like
by
random corruption even like that's even
like a worse problem at this point like
it's random corruption
like in snow weather distribution shift
that's a serious problem
which my other paper actually kind of
targets like you know the adversarial
examples
paper tries to tackle basically you know
robustness
to like changing the game basically to
achieve robustness on like
common corruptions which is actually you
know a more like direct problem that we
have right now
it's like a problem of distribution
shift which is more severe in my opinion
at this moment
of time like we have to solve that
before so i mean
it's good if we solve that example
that's good that's good but like i think
this is like
a more prominent problem at this moment
at this moment like we have to solve
that
even because okay the best in the ideal
world
there will not be adversaries but they
will be there will be like random noise
and corruptions and the ideal world so
they will happen eventually yeah yeah
yeah exactly
on that exactly i think the distribution
shift a lot of this comes back to
generalization right
you said we we need better priors i i
like charles conception that we need to
have human prize in our models and most
of the prize we have in our models at
the moment actually
um are to improve the information
conversion ratio right there's this
realization that
uh most of the information out there in
the universe is just it's like the
kaleidoscope effector charlay says it's
just it's a very small amount of
information which is represented in lots
of different ways so we need to
improve the efficiency in in doing so
but i i wanted to come back quickly to
um because you know we've been talking
about um the the randomized smoothing
and and the noise models and stuff but
but that your your main contribution
recently actually was this
incredible concept of unadversarial
examples and
we haven't really properly spoken about
this but it's this idea that you can
have a patch
or even a texture you did a version in
3d where
if you if you create the right kind of
patch
you can actually reinforce the model
making the correct prediction even under
a variety of different background
conditions and noise and so on so
can you just go go through really
clearly what that process is
yeah yeah so this is the most exciting
work recently i'd like
i i i'm still super like every time i
like you know see it i'm like you know
think about it i get i just get super
excited
it's just like you know it's very simple
idea like super simple
okay we have those adversary examples or
adversarial perturbations
that you know easily break our models so
we are able to add like small non-robust
features
which them which our models love right
like
whenever they see these non-robust
features oh i love them i'll go there
i'll i'll see what they're saying i'll
i'll do it
it's super robust to the rotations
transformations to everything
like whatever like whenever they see it
like even if there's like so much like
other information like another bus like
there there's like
the image of the dog but like small
noise or like
features of a cat oh this is a cat
amazing so i was like
holy like why don't we just like
that's how the models perceive
our models currently that's how they
perceive we don't like it
we don't we want them to perceive like
us but they're currently that's how they
perceive the world
so why don't we design the world for
them in that way
so i was like why don't we just like
bring those features okay you like this
feature this is this is this is the
picture of a cup
you know it doesn't make sense for us
for humans that's fine
it makes sense for neural networks let's
use it so what we basically did is that
we just like brought like created those
non robust features
but for the right class so in a simple
setting you know we just bring
an object so so this thing doesn't like
we basically try to like
color or like paste some patch or like
redesign or color an
object of interest so that whenever the
new network sees it
it sees that those non-robust features
of this object along with robust
features of course but in addition like
we kind of
amplify the non-robust features so like
in your example that you like like the
cat with a furry would just make the fur
more furrier like i don't know like
more farrier for a neural network right
so whenever they see the neural actually
sees this oh this is a cup for sure
even if there's some other like you know
noise or distribution shift or
transformation it actually works
so the key there was also like trying to
testing this under like all sorts of
corruptions not that only test time
corruptions
like all sort of like the corruptions
that imagenet c has
and it works really well it's like those
and like underwater features actually
like are really
salient even under like the worst none
kind of like
common corruption which which like
whenever we paste them on our objects
we see the objects even under like weird
distribution shits
the easy way to do this would be to say
okay well
here's a cat i'm going to put an
un-adversarial
patch on the cat which has the
non-robust features of a cat
clearly that would be cheating wouldn't
it because i'm not supposed to know what
the picture
is before i put the pattern on so so
hold on like mix them together
no this is a great point like the the
key the key okay
the key of this paper is that it's not
like it's like changing the game
for a specific scenario for specific
scenarios in the world like of course
this is not gonna work if you wanna like
go
train a model and go outside and like
detect dogs and cats it's not gonna work
because we are not controlling the dogs
and cats
but in many many scenarios we have
like the system designer or like you
know the human has control not only on
the model
but only also on the objects of interest
that they are trying to recognize
detect track so like the way i actually
came up with this is that i was working
with
with microsoft with some researcher on
like some like project with like on
helicopters and stuff like
with some company and we're like how can
we robotify landing or something like
how can we how can we like apply
knowledge like to make landing of
like helicopters or like drones safer
or like more robust under severe weather
conditions i was like thinking we're
discussing
alexander madrid was there as well you
know along with like ashish kapoor from
microsoft and sai
vamprada as well and we were thinking
and i was like holy like why don't
we just like
redesign this like why do we design this
landing pad like that
why don't we redesign it in a way that
new networks love to see
and there with with that actually idea
came from there like why
like for such for such for such a
scenario we
we have uh control of what models what
perception model we want to deploy on
the helicopter for example
but also we have control of the object
of interest this applies also for like
stop signs
for an autonomous vehicles we designed
the stop sign right we designed like
that because the humans recognize it
like that
why don't we have another stop sign for
example for it for you know next to it
for thomas drive like autonomous
vehicles or like in a warehouse you know
or in kitchen let's say in a kitchen you
have like a robot that's doing the
dishes and stuff
why do you want to color the dish like
that why don't you color it in ways so
that like it's much more robustly
classified and recognized
and detected by the model and the idea
is very simple it's just like you know
doing adversarial attack
targeted at risk attack but towards the
correct class like it's actually just
literally literally reversing the story
just like
just instead of training the model train
the object train the input so back
regate and update the
texture in the input space like in the
3d texture so we use like you know some
like non-different uh sorry
differentiable
renderer and stuff do that so so like
the demonstration that i have on like
image net and like 2d images is just
like you know a proof of concept and
like a systemic way to analyze those
patches but like ideally you will
actually create 3d models or like 2d
patches and print them and paste them on
objects you're not going to like modify
to the images because that's cheating
so of course to to clarify a bit more
there used to be this demonstration
which i found pretty cool when i got
into kind of uh computer science of an
engineering professor here at eth
of raft andrea and he had these drones
and i think it was a ted talk and these
drones they could do like amazing things
with like balls that he
threw up in the air right yeah and the
point of the story was there are like
cameras in the room that track
the drones and the ball and they were
made specifically like bright red and
round
because right we can build cool computer
vision detectors like a half
transform and the color is really
distinct so we can like
pinpoint where that is so in a way
that's what we did before
we designed objects that these cameras
and our systems can track really well
but now we
we can do it even better because we have
back propagation so we don't we don't
have to think like
exactly what do our systems like we can
just ask them and then
right they can exactly my question is um
you know given that you can do this with
a network you can take a network and you
can see what does the network love
and you can put that somewhere and it
will be recognized
very robustly do you also
modify the network itself because you
could think of this as like a two-player
game right where
you create a patch network
combo that is just like so and that
would be i think mainly a function of
the
of course right like the that's like the
complete system will be determined by
what corruptions you want to be robust
to
so you kind of build a network patch
combo that that just loves each other
like is that no this is a
yeah this is a great point like this is
actually a setting which we did not
discuss in our paper but it's like you
know a direct setting which is
basically joint training of your model
and your patch we did it it actually
achieved similar results but like
because it's not like as clean we just
like avoid like talking about it and let
it
left it for like you know uh future work
so what we did is just that we fixed the
pre-trained model so just like bring any
pre-trained model fix it
okay even if it's a randomly initialized
model like the crazy thing if
bring and randomly initialize the model
and just like optimize the patch with
respect to this model
so minimize the loss so usually we
minimize those with respect to the
parameters of this model
so don't do that just like minimize the
loss respect to other set of parameters
which is basically the texture
so optimize your input or your objects
of interest
so it works really well like even on a
random initialized model so like i think
there's a random initialized model
you deploy it like this might be you
know something like like it's just like
random totally rather
maybe maybe it has applications in
privacy or something i don't know like
if you don't your model to be hacked or
something
it's random and then you design your
objects of interest so the model is like
for anyone who see it or try to hack it
or something it's random like it's not
gonna do anything
but like whenever it sees the object of
interest it's just gonna get super
exciting and it will detect it
so we just focused on pre-trained models
but totally
you like yeah it's like you can achieve
even better results by like
jointly training them you can achieve as
good as results if you join the trains
training because it's just going to
improve your model so maybe like you
alternate like minimize the inputs
the parameters then it will minimize the
parameters of the input that you can
alternate or like do crazy stuff
but but but totally like you you touched
the exact point like
we design objects because we think oh
like red color and shiny color might be
you know interesting for this system
it might be better for this model but
doing it in a data different way like is
definitely better
like like you just like collect data and
do it like it's just like making your
life easier
we tried bass lines of random colors and
you know like something that makes sense
for humans
it doesn't work as well as you know uh
like i have some some examples in the
paper like doesn't work as well as
you know did like designing it and did a
different way so literally it's just
like applying you know a data different
way
to design objects for neural networks
like that's that's what excites me like
it's
foreign like from the perspective of new
networks we are redesigning the world
i don't know this is a wider ranging
application
application so i mean first of all the
probably the jointly trained thing would
probably be
extremely vulnerable to other serial
attacks so maybe that's
you know maybe that kind of blocks those
things from being deployed
but um i think the applications of this
are much more wide-ranging because
this comes very close to for example
data augmentation and data driven data
augmentation like to
to to really understand what kind of
things the neural networks
like will probably also make you then
able
to design data augmentation algorithms
for
classifiers when you can say okay what
does this network
really love and you know probably
you know we should we should augment our
data in such a way either to
reinforce or to to completely go counter
to that
depending on what we see in the data
right yeah yeah yeah
yeah i mean yeah could i tell a couple
of clarifying questions because i i
still
don't feel i completely understand this
so
it's a wonderful concept the way we
design uh stop
signs right on the side of the road
they're big and red and red you know we
we our brain lights up so they light up
like a christmas tree for us
i understand the concept is similar to
like a helipad or a runway
we make it light up like a christmas
tree so we can reinforce it so so i
understand correctly
this is very similar to the work you
know when they could make a turtle look
like a rifle
in 3d or you could put an adversarial
patch on a human being and
an existing vision model would think it
was something else so this is very much
for the regime where you actually know
what you want it to classify right so
i'm going to make a patch which will
look as much
like an airplane as possible so you are
so it's not it's not for any class it's
for a particular class
and then i'm going to stick that patch
on an image because then it makes me
think well
so you're taking a non-robust feature
and you're increasing the magnitude of
it because normally it's quite low
magnitude but exactly
i bet that works quite well for the
setting where you have a pre-trained
model
but why don't you just throw the whole
thing out and start again you know what
why even use a pre-trained model why
don't you come up with the equivalent of
a qr code and
not even use the original model at all
why don't you just change the whole
pipeline
so like the other option is just like
training the model jointly with the
patch
i mean you either train the model which
is what we do you know
you just bring someone some models and
you can some objects and like data set
and you train on them so that's what
usually we do right like people do
the other thing is just fix the model
and train the patch or like the
input or like the object of interest
just to design this structure
and the third option is like train them
jointly
which is possible yeah we like it's
possible i'm saying and it's it it's
like
it actually it will achieve as good as
like you know just training the patch
because
you can start from every random not from
a random nationalism you can start from
a pre-trained model or any model you
want and just like
try to like improve that more and more
you are basically minimizing the loss
your objective function instead of just
like with respect to the model also with
respect to the other set of parameters
which is also like the patches
and like a crucial thing with the
parameters of the patch
or the texture the crucial thing here is
that uh i don't know
someone mentioned that like uh that like
we have to like include like
corruptions in the training pipeline
like the nice thing is that we don't
actually do that
like because we cannot like model or
kind of like corruptions
in the world we just it like the nice
thing about this method is like we it
doesn't it didn't see any corruption any
random corruption any noise any
any like snow or anything during
training time but at this time it
generalizes really well to them whenever
it sees those saving features
like that's the cool thing and we
specific of course we can like probably
pipe in like
common corruption add more corruption
during training which will make it even
more and more robust but we wanted to
show that
it hasn't seen any corruption because in
the world it's it might actually
come with like uh sorry like see
corruptions that haven't seen before
so we wanted to demonstrate that it
actually generalizes really well but
totally if you if you if you know them
what about the corruption is that it's
gonna
the data augmentation will help it even
more and more so you will have aerobic
like
instead of doing expectation over like
rotations and like transformations of
the of the patch
you can actually do expectation over
also like corruptions as well so you can
train the patch with
expectation over corruptions over
everything that you know of corruptions
of transformations over
other data points of everything
basically
uh and minimize the loss expect explain
value of the loss uh but yeah so
it's really it's it's it's really really
general but yeah you totally can train
both the models and the patch
but we didn't like in this uh invest a
lot in that yeah go ahead what's up
i think in in this regard a paper
that really shows some positive
direction is
the self training with noisy student
training paper
where the student is actually
made made to you know learn and ensemble
of a harder teacher model so you have
clean set of images you pass it to some
well-trained
teacher model you take those predictions
as the ground truth levels
for the student model and while passing
the images to the student model you
heavily augment it with
transformations like brand augment and
you ask it to be consistent
with both these different versions of
images so that way you went for some
you know some sense of consistency and
at the same time the
teacher has higher capacity uh than the
student while
you are training it so and that has many
nice properties such as
improved robustness to common
corruptions and also
some level of adversarial robustness to
adversarial perturbations in
particular l2 uh attacks so they did not
you know do anything provably but they
did
show empirically this works this yields
better
robustness to certain adversarial
perturbations so i think
having some sense of consistency
regulation might be also helpful
along with stronger data augmentation
policies so
yeah you can you can you can do all
sorts of stuff like anything that you
can you do for your model
you can just now do it for your input
like any any like sort of like data
augmentation or like you know
tricks you do to optimize your model
better you think about it you have
another kind of like set of parameters
you're optimizing
which you can see that's that's the only
thing like you cannot see actually like
the parameters of the model but you can
see the parameters of the
of the object that you're optimizing
yeah like the color it is also
very coherent with human perception to
some extent because inherently we are
training our model that
that okay this is my image and if i am
being a little bit
darker inside some dark light then it
should be my image
as well right i mean inherently training
my
mind to believe that sort of stuff it's
actually it's essentially like telling
you telling me like oh if i see
like uh i don't know like it's just it's
just like telling like adding adding
more more information to the model like
is it
like my i don't know like some my friend
telling me oh if you see me like
i will always wear yellow okay so just
like
whenever it's yellow like i have more
confidence like if i see him from far
away if there's more confidence
that this is this guy because he i have
a little bit more information that this
you know
this is this guy because he had this
information that i will always
you know wear yellow in addition to his
feature expressions and stuff i will
that that will be persistent like there
yeah i would have more information that
he passed to me when he told me like i
would always like you know
that is exactly what the recovery
training sort of tries to do
so that is the beauty of that method i
guess and i also wanted to ask another
point is with randomized smoothing i
guess
this is one of the cases where a network
a network sense of perception is not
that much
inherent i mean coherent with how we
perceive things
right because uh you i mean
uh sorry that was not randomized
smoothing that has to be with
unadversarial objects because we were
mentioning that we
are trying to you know maximize the uh
perception capability
for a neural network but that might not
be again coherent with how
we perceive things don't you think this
is another
case where uh both the perceptual
capabilities
sort of very different while we are
trying to constrain our models to
be as coherent with how perceived how we
perceive things
i mean it really depends like on the
situation on the task like some tasks we
don't interact with them at all only
robots interact with them like
hopefully at some point like the robots
only will do dishes or like you know
will
uh wipe the house or something you know
like we will not care how how things are
you know designed
uh maybe at some point you know even
stop signs we will not be driving at all
i don't know maybe this will happen
this will come so we don't care about
how the stop sign is designed
but if there are tasks that you know
humans and robots are you know
uh doing it to get simultaneously
we can even we can either leave it as is
because a human like know how to detect
shapes much much better than networks
and networks care about the textures
so maybe like let's just like you know
give textures draw it to machines and
shapes to humans or like you know
regularize like add some regularizations
on how we paint the object so we can add
you know we can
like now it's like all sort of like kind
of like looks noisy and like you know
similar to
adversary examples you know very noisy
very hurting to the eye maybe
we can optimize and like you know some
color space or something you can like
you know
optimize not in the pixel space you can
like add some like function and optimize
that function you know to like optimize
the model so you can literally totally
optimize what color should be not like
or what it tricks it should be what the
total color should be you can optimize
that you can like add regular you can do
literally
whatever you want it goes into the
direction of these people who train like
gans to produce
adversarial examples right so you know
like you have like a gan that produces
images and then you find something in
its latent space
and it goes yeah yeah i think
if you want a good example for
unadversarial examples for humans it's
branding
so like you know you could you could uh
you could teach a human to make the
association of like
expensive nice shoes that last for a
while and make me good at sports
or you could just put like a little
check mark on it right and like the
human like it's it's like this direct
hack into the human brain
it which is which is branding and that's
exactly what what these unadversarial
examples
for the neural networks right it's like
you can either learn this whole
complicated stuff or i'm just gonna
you know slap this piece of thing on
here and i i make your
you associate that with the correct
class oh yeah this is this is a great
great example great motivation yeah this
is
[Laughter]
well on that note
i'm gonna wrap things up but um uh hi
dear simon thank you so much for joining
us today it's been an absolute honour
and
uh yeah it was it was really really cool
having one
thank you thank you for having me it's
been a it's a pleasure and i really
enjoyed the the show and
uh yeah really nice work and you know
you do a lot of hard work like you know
there's like i don't like the show every
two weeks like it takes a lot of time to
prepare i totally
can imagine that so like it's really
impressive yeah thanks for having me on
and yeah let's just see like where this
channel goes and like
how much we can advance ai as well but
yeah you're doing great job guys like
happy to be here thanks thanks so much
it was actually every one week but yeah
i think just
everything we've recently gone down to
every two weeks because as you can
imagine it's quite a lot of work
yeah anyway right i can imagine
[Music]